that's why when i was playing
i didn't want to be the great the
greatest player ever or the best player
ever they all pass around too much but
you know words you're not passing around
the most dominant ever
there was only one at the time now
there's two
[Music]
wow how many times did you have to
practice
your entrance shaq what entrance just
just me being myself surviving
barely fitting in the chair what is this
can you move this little table yes you
can
it's so funny because you probably
experience life so much differently than
me just because you're so much bigger
it's not true taylor it's not no i don't
have to worry like can i fit into this
place can i be here will i have to duck
my head i feel like you're always having
to think about that no no just living
life that's why i hit my head all the
time
and that makes sense that makes a lot of
sense um so i honestly kind of just want
to like dive right in with the news of
what's happening in this moment and
that's you and rudy gobert okay i spoke
to rudy okay i said you know i'm gonna
be talking to shaq today do you have
anything that you would like to say let
me tell you
okay yes got it so he first off wanted
to make it abundantly clear he has no
beef with you he said i don't have beef
with shaq
he said
yes like i do think i could lock him up
i'm never gonna look at someone whoever
it is and say yeah you would score 40 on
me that's not my mentality i would love
to go against prime shack it would be a
great challenge for me and i said and
what makes you so confident you would
lock him up he said that's the way you
have to think or you have no chance but
please tell shaq i appreciate the love
and you know what rudy let me tell you
something i respect that
i do all right
so a lot of times when i throw jabs
people think it's hate or whatever
but it's really i'm just challenging
them
because this thing we have right now is
so good
if it continues to be great everybody
will prosper
that's how you got to look at it so
before i came in it was great
when i came in it was still great
those guys left we made it greater we're
still here it's the greatest game ever
we leave oh kobe's here made it great
it's a great thing we have so it's my
job to push the needle not i know how to
push the needle so you you earthlings
when you hear me say something you may
think oh he's
he's hating like i said donovan mitchell
is a really good player that don't even
sound right to me
it should be donovan mitch was one of
the greatest guards ever that's what it
should be so my question to people like
donovan are are you satisfied with being
a really good player or do you want to
be great you want to be great show me
and if i say something prove me wrong
it's it's never beef when i speak i
think i speak from experience
and i have g19 classification to say
what i say yeah i'm not one of these
other commentators who didn't do
anything
you know who i am you know what i did
and when it comes to position like that
i've seen greatness i've i've helped
bring greatness up
i played with penny i played with kobe i
played with d wade i play with brian i
play with nash
so i know what greatness is so when i
see somebody that has that it's my job
to push him but again when i when i say
oh he's hating no i don't
i don't have to hate brother
well i think sometimes at least to me it
feels like
even more so than just like challenging
them it almost feels like you're testing
them like testing how they're going to
react to this criticism from you or
criticism from anyone
that's exactly what i'm doing when i
when i was running my teams i do that i
got to know that i could i could say
something to kelly
she has tough skin
i gotta know i could say something to
this camera man right here he has tough
skin if i say something to kelly and she
doesn't fight back i gotta ease up
if i say something to him and he fights
but hey man move the camera right i'm
moving it now i know i got some money
there when it comes time to you know get
in the trenches he's going to be there
right there with me and that just tells
that you're aficionado very professional
about what you do that's why you're well
respected in this industry because you
pay attention
so the fact that you know that and you
don't even know me but the fact that you
know that and these players don't oh man
you hating
why would i hate on you what have you
done that i haven't done
like you know that's the go-to word
where you hating no man i don't
i don't know at all i'm right there i'm
actually giving you answers to the test
yeah i'm helping you get to here
because if we don't protect them the
people ain't going to protect them
either
so when you think about you know
throwing out these tests gauging you
know how they react and things like that
who sticks out in your mind as you know
some players who have passed that test
and some players who have failed that
test all my guys have passed the test
okay all the guys i played for hope you
don't think our relationship has been
nah it's
been remember and they passed all of
them passed penny
kobe d wade i i i didn't have to deal
with brown because brown was already
established but
it didn't have to do with nash but you
know all the guys that i played with
guys that i was responsible for pass
with flying colors that's how i know
i know
this works
that's how i know what greatness is
because i've seen it yeah i've seen them
practice i've seen the game i've seen
the tough situations i've seen in times
where we got swept how you gonna bounce
back i've seen it
the ones that failed i don't i don't i
don't give them a second chance
i'll give them a second chance i'm
trying to help you you want to get all
sensitive and call your mother and have
your mother call my mother no problem i
won't say nothing else i won't ever say
it again did someone have their mom call
your mom yeah
who i'm like i can't do that
but a play a current player has had
their mother
reach out to you
no reach out to my mother to your mother
about something that you said yeah and
my mother said baby stop you being hard
on them yes ma'am
and my mother's my woman whenever she
says do something i don't question it
yes ma'am so
i'm not even allowed to say this
player's name anymore
really because the power of the moms yes
because like certain people get
sensitive and you know but unless you
have to understand it's never personal
women
this is what leaders do you have to
you know see what the people that work
for you the people that work with you
you have to see what they
they can handle you have to modulate
your own behavior to see what they can
and cannot take
so on this subject another thing that
people have been discussing is ben
simmons and ben simmons retweeted
something that implied that he believes
you owe him a poli an apology who
you
apology for what things that you have
said about his situation his injury his
do you think there's any merit to that
no that's never going to happen
okay
do you feel like everything you've said
about ben was fair i don't know what i
said but i i know i wasn't being
dishonest
like everything i said i thought was
facts let's see let's go to fact number
one you didn't want to shoot in the
fourth quarter
why because you didn't want to get fired
you want to go to the live that's fact
am i correct
okay okay the other situation
uh me and him we didn't really spoke but
he tweeted me and i said well
when you don't
answer the questions that people are
asking people speculate
and now with everybody having to say so
speculation's going to be what it is
he's like you're wrong i said look
i left it alone
but
you know
if something's wrong with me
and you depend on me i'm gonna tell you
what's wrong with me
i can't do the interview today
my shoulder i can't even turn left i
don't want to do the whole interview
like that not i'm not coming
i'm not coming
taylor won't talk to you i don't care
i'm not coming so
when you leave people room to speculate
everybody gonna make their own
speculation
uh if i said something
that was hurtful
maybe he should call me and say hey you
said this and then i will
i'm intelligent enough to stop time and
say okay when did i say
you know what that wasn't right my bad
big homie but
right now we're just going off of
speculation and some facts because i got
people where he is
so i know a lot and i see a lot but
you know we don't
he hasn't said why he wanted why why
he's not playing
what i would do
because i've been in that situation you
know you don't think i missed free
throws coming on the stretch you don't
think people
talked about me
uh they have
but the way they face fear is you gotta
gotta look in an eye
that's ten free throws in a row down by
one all you gotta do is make one
all you gotta do is make one and go to
the finals and people who love you if
you miss
they're gonna be talking about you all
summer yeah just make that one i've been
in that situation my whole life and
guess what when i need to make that one
i make the one
and then you know you get you get your
wish you get traded to another team and
you're still not playing
you have to say why you're not playing
and now all of a sudden it's back
surgery no i'm not
i'm not going to apologize because i
don't feel i said anything wrong but if
i get a call from the godmother
then then
i'm so sorry i hurt your feelings i
apologize
but until then
but i mean i do think you guys probably
would genuinely benefit from having an
actual conversation about what i don't
know but i think that all things listen
i don't need to compensate with no
earthlings compensate about what i said
what i said
this is no this is not this this is
sports this is our world and this is how
we live
listen and and that this thing yeah
i'm hard i got to stay hard i don't let
nothing come in
yeah if you look at me walk i walk funny
you know why because i did it for the
people i played
i played see it's the difference between
being injured and hurt
everybody's injured my man right here
he's been he's been working here 20 30
years you don't think his back hurting
my man right here every i i've been
seeing him for a long time you know you
don't think my man is tired they're
injured but they got to work
see we're the only sport where you can
be injured and be a baby and say oh i
don't want to do it and still get paid
i don't respect people like that i
respect these people
the hard-working people of america
i'm injured now my damn hips hurt but
you think i can call over there with
chuck ernie and kenny said no i'm not
coming to work today you know what
draymond gonna be in my seat
that's what's gonna happen so no i'm not
apologizing nobody
for what
that's fair that's fair i do think just
to play devil's out of kit it's probably
people feeling like
is it as simple as that
i don't know because nobody's saying
anything yeah so when somebody says
something if i made a mistake dr
shaquille o'neal would be the first guy
to say
i messed up i think this is a this is a
moment where
ben would benefit by speaking to people
because it does cut out that speculation
but also with things like mental health
if he is dealing with anxiety if this is
something that he is battling it is hard
to confront those issues at times but we
all have these questions because we're
like well why are you doing that this
doesn't make sense i know this that in
the third
but nobody truly knows what's going on
true or false besides ben if you have
anxiety shooting free throws you having
anxiety putting on green leather and 300
000 worth of change when people like
here that work hard never seen a million
dollars like do you have anxiety then
when you're sitting on the bench these
are questions i want to ask experts
i can understand you have anxiety in the
game but when you not playing and you're
sitting on the bench
and you know 300 000 gucci and the big
chains and rings what do you have
anxiety then
that's all i want to know
because remember i respect these people
right here the hard-working people of
america i don't represent the rich
fruitful people that that's not who i
represent yeah cause remember there's a
difference between injured and hurt
everybody in the world is injured but we
have to work some people got to work
check to check for their whole life
we don't but some people don't and this
is who i represent so sometimes they
don't have a voice but i have a voice
and again if i'm wrong about certain
things i'll be the first one to
apologize because i don't try to be
disrespectful but when i don't know
something i gotta ask questions
how do you think
shaq would have reacted to a shack like
media figure
like when you were playing if there was
somebody who was you
in the media how do you think you would
have gotten along with him there's a lot
of me his name is stephen a smith
but when you were in your prime steven
smith but at your level oh stephen a
smith used to tell crazy charles talk
crazy can he tell crazy it's only one
thing you can do is shut them up
oh shaq's never going to win when
championship shooting 40 from the
freezing line okay watch this
you just shut them up that's all you
don't cry i'm not going to call and
chuck them and beat your ass when i see
you wanted to
but hey man everybody everybody has an
opinion
but see if you hard on yourself the
opinions
don't matter
lions don't listen to the opinions of
sheep
this world we live in now with 100
million voices i don't know can't
knock on
bro i used to hear it all the time
when i like kevin durant i swept one
time i got swept five times you don't
think i i heard oh you he's not that
great same thing i'm saying to uh
donovan mitchell kareem said to me
you know article i was hurt
i'm averaging i'm averaging kareem like
numbers and they said man shaq's one of
the best lakers since kareem and kareem
was we didn't have twitter kareem talked
to reporters that is he that great they
get swept every year he's not winning
championships
i can't cry to kareem abdul-jabbar i
ain't got that g14 classification
so at some point you have to listen to
criticism and see if there's some truth
behind it
he was right yes jack's hygiene 38 but
they got swept by utah they got swept by
the spurs
so instead of being wimpy about it you
man up
and you get it done so you know all the
stuff that these guys are going through
i've been through
i may have invented it
i don't go
no i mad up
my father was harder than any other
cricket
critic in the world
i have 50 one time when i missed 12 free
throws you should have had 60 mama
yeah
like so
yeah it just you know it
depends on who you are
and i'm programmed not to make any
excuses
and never let no excuses come in
and it's not something that i made up
magic and i have no excuses isaiah
thomas i have no excuses dr j didn't
have no excuses muhammad ali didn't have
no excuses so why can't i have an excuse
and i'm making more than any of them
ever made they paved the way for me i'm
representing for them too yeah thank you
mr kareem abdul-jabbar sir because of
what you and mr bill russell had to go
bill russell
couldn't even stand at the hotel with
this with his homeboys yeah couldn't
even drink in certain fountains
and now they're saying i'm the next bill
russell i'm
i'm representing that
why i'm flying private
i got sweets and everything who am i to
complain i ain't complaining about
nothing thank you mr russell now i'm a
representative for you that's how i
think and i don't know if they make them
like that anymore so a lot of times when
i do stuff and say stuff it may come out
the wrong way but
you got to understand me and understand
my intentions yeah
i mean i do think one thing you said is
true which is winning really is that
cure to everything if somebody has
things to say about you you go out there
you prove them wrong and that narrative
will change
while that's easier said than done i do
believe what you're saying is true it's
very easy yeah
easy to win a championship yes it is
i mean i think most nba players would
disagree it's easy to i mean like they
would not think it's easy to win an nba
championship that's why it's them so
coveted because it's difficult if you
have the right components it's easy
right but think about how difficult it
is to get the right components
yeah but if you call yourself a great
player
then
that's the start of having the right
components right for sure but i know you
don't think winning a championship is
easy i know that you do not believe that
to be true because that's why you have
so much pride in it because it's hard to
get there it's not hard it's easy no
it's hard to get there but once you get
there listen once they say you're a
great player and you got another great
player with you you got all you need
you got all you need
every team don't have that but once your
team has that you got everything you
need
no excuses none
that's why i used to get so mad when we
used to get swept i'm like damn i got
everything i need
like damn me kobe big shout out we just
and then you just gotta
you keep fighting and you just get it
done once we got it done what happened
we got three in a row but it took time
and i think for some of this player it's
taking the time of that but it's still
easy trust me
so easy to get that trophy you know it's
easy because i'm programmed to
when stuff is difficult i break it down
to as easy as phone
like for example if i bought this camera
i don't know nothing about what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna call my main man he's
gonna show me what the power button is
he's gonna show me where the zoom is now
i know how to work the camera i'm not
about to sit there and read the damn
manual
so when stuff is hard you gotta you know
break it down till it's easy so yes it's
easy to win once you get the components
you need then it's easy
okay fair i think it's
i think that's simplifying it a bit but
i feel you it it may take you a while to
get there yes it may take you a while to
break it down to its easiest form but
once i got got the book
three
that's why i knocked off three in a row
because you had figured it out yeah and
then you kept going i think a theme that
kind of resonates to me when i watch one
inside the nba or just like watch any of
your interviews is
it seems like you believe we have kind
of diluted the word greatness like we're
kind of calling all these players great
yes you have yeah
explain to me why you believe that to be
true because because you have
not you you just have i mean
greatness to me is is ah
and all it takes now is somebody to do
an odd move when you guys are giving it
to them
and then you know when they know and
then when they hear it they think that
and then when they don't play like that
and then you question that no i'm great
taylor says great and then when a great
one says no you're not great or you're
just hating because you're old and i'm
playing amen so yes you guys have dylan
that little the word that's why when i
was playing
i didn't want to be the the great the
greatest player ever or the best player
ever y'all passing around too much but
you know words you're not passing around
the most dominant ever
it was only one at the time now there's
two
that's it that's two when you talk about
the most dominant ever to play this game
it's only two i can live in that in that
in that uh
in that
community
i can live in that residential area i
don't want to be
man who's the best kobe lebron
michael too many people
too many people man who's a bit
like my lane two people the dominant is
your and that's why i wanted to pass him
up in points
because i was going to have an arrogant
speech for the whole world i'm the most
dominant ever i don't want to hear
nobody's name i got more championships i
got more points shut it up be quiet me
me me me me but i didn't pass them up
and i passed them up in championship but
i didn't pass them up from point so i'm
gonna give her misses respect and
i will allow you to say will chamberlain
or she killed me it was the most
dominant level i can live with that but
i'm telling you if i had to pass that
man up a point
we would still be hearing about it for
one day only i was going to hear a very
arrogant check i wasn't going to be
playing i was going to say me
me yeah
you know a lot of like i said a lot of
stuff y'all just throw around it's cool
just doing your job but
since i've been with greatness i i
really i really know what greatness is
you know a word i think that is thrown
around a lot is superstar you think that
there is a very big difference between a
star and a superstar so i'm going to ask
somebody who has a superstar what do you
think that difference is
i don't know
you don't know the difference between
star and superstar no
okay tell me in the nba right now who
are superstars i don't know
how not oh steph curry is a superstar
okay
superstar
who else i'm not sure you say steffianes
yeah you don't say i mean i'm assuming
you say lebron oh yeah bro yeah yeah
okay i assume you say kd
yeah i guess yeah okay
do you put
kawhi
i don't know do you
i think there was like a time i was like
yeah superstar he's star for sure but
right now i don't know if i would say so
is he a superstar is that i think right
now i say star
i'll start yeah okay cool so then you
answer your own question yeah okay good
but you you have no other superstars
there's four for you there's four
superstars
i know what the definition is but i
don't know what your definition is and
that's why i'm asking you what's your
definition of suicide before that we
named
okay chris paul probably put him in
there with that you put chris paul yeah
probably put him in there with that but
i don't i don't know i try not to
you know sometimes you just have to
remove yourself so if so if it's not on
a tuesday or thursday
yeah
to be fair it's tuesday
okay so
we're working now so i'm in this
situation but if i'm not working i'm
removed from the situation okay
this is completely random but it's a
story that i heard that i want to know
from you
so they say that there would be times
that you would practice naked
is that true
your teammates are on record one two
three discussing it i'm not gonna answer
that with four ladies present
why and the cameraman and the director
talking well while i'm talking
i can guarantee pro none of us practice
naked yeah you would come onto the court
and practice the whole process no but
you would appear for a minute
is that true or false
false
so your teammates just made that up
i don't know who said that
he was like derek fisher he said
sometimes like you would come out
you were late
and you couldn't be late and you didn't
have time to put your clothes on
so was i really late though
so
hold on so this happened then you did
sometimes appear naked i was never late
that's all you need to know
yeah you were never late because you
were naked on the court
no just it's just not true i can't
answer that with four lovely ladies and
if this was all god's podcast i'd tell
you the truth nothing but the truth but
since we have i can guarantee you we're
the same and we truly
don't care i'm looking at supermodels
and
[Music]
lawyers and doctors and producers nope
can't do it well you have confirmed it
without confirming it just so
you have because if you would have just
said no i did that false what taylor
rook said about me
is okay whatever you say uh another
thing uh i went to claire bob obviously
it's like a narrative about you and the
free throws
um that it wasn't your strong suit but i
don't know if you've ever been asked
like why why was it so hard for you
to make free throws it wasn't hard
okay
i think
it was
the man's way of keeping me humble
you had of one thing you couldn't do
yeah kept me humble imagine my game and
me shooting like steph curry
imagine that
my game me
and i could shoot like steph curry
i know for a fact i'd be a hard
individual to deal with
so sometimes you need certain things to
keep you humble
like my mother's is a certain thing that
keeps me humble
don't say that don't do that
that was that thing and practice at the
house i'd hit him
i used to be a shooter i actually
started off a shooter in high school
really i used to shoot jump shots
because i couldn't
i didn't want to dump
because i'm like magic was my guy i
wanted to be like magic i'd rather come
down give it to my boy
right and one game true story got 45 and
three quarters we killing this little
team i crossed the dude off for half
court
i lay it i finger oh what i miss
my father comes on the court in the
church call the timeout like yo man call
the timeout like every time i come
outside say what yo what you doing say
man i'm working on my whap
so now i'm also programmed not to cry
get your ass back in there and dunk it
that's why when i dunk i try to rip the
rim off because i was always mad at him
a lot of people don't know this story
that's why when i dunk i kick and i
craig cause i'm trying to rip the rim
off so from that day on i stopped
shooting jumpers and started dunking and
then when i realized when i dunked
people would go like this i was like oh
once again the sarge was right i got
something
i got something that's why when i dunk i
kicked my legs and go crazy i don't care
i was actually trying to rip the rim
down and we had those rims in the thing
so when i dunk it was like a small
school but you see the whole thing
and everybody knew what i was doing and
after the time i i told my guys anybody
shoot i'm punching in your face
i'm ripping the rim off today and then
every time i dunk my father go
boom
i end up with 65 that game but it was
like boom boom and then on the way home
in the car he didn't say nothing
and then right before we got in the
house i need you to do that for the rest
of your life
and that's how i started dunking so i i
i used to be a shooter to shoot but that
moment like with your dad changed
essentially your whole style your whole
playing card it did
so
and i shot pretty good in high school
but when i hit that switch if i need do
we need one i never miss
i never miss so you know
because my other game was perfect people
wanted my whole game to be perfect it's
not going to be happening but
it's not going to stop me
ain't going to make me slow down what
i'm doing it's never going to make me
get down on myself
you said i'm programmed not to cry what
does that mean i've been programmed i
probably only cried three times in my
whole life
listen i grew up with a drill sergeant
five o'clock wake up make your bed flip
the cord on the bed and do it right do
it again rake the leaves cut the thing
this this is how you speak to people
respect
don't do this don't do that also program
not to make the same mistake twice
so if i do make a mistake and say
something and i have to apologize for it
i don't never say it again i go right up
here in the file and i hit delete it'll
never happen again
so you said you cried three times what
were those times grandmother sister and
kobe
four and my father
that's it
so for you side cries i've cried tears
of joy a lot with those don't got like
side cries four times
do you feel like
being programmed not to cry allows you
to actually feel emotions or do you
sometimes feel like they're bottled up i
don't have time to feel emotions
why because when you're put in a certain
position
you have to make sure everybody else is
okay
i don't use the term baby mamas i have
two lovely women that i'm responsible
for
even if they're in a relationship i'm
responsible for you it's a man's job to
protect provider love
i have six children that i'm responsible
for i have a mother that i'm responsible
for i got one remaining brother one
remaining sister that i'm responsible
for before i think about myself i have
to think about them and by the time i
think about dental every day then i
gotta go to work it's 2 a.m so i don't
have time to have an emotion the only
thing i got time to do smoke my hookah
and watch some netflix
and that's why my day is beautiful
because i i got to make sure you i ain't
got time to be oh my god no mommy you
okay
you're honey you're okay that's a man's
job and
i live a good life
and again i think about all these people
these hard working people live a good
life i ain't got time to complain about
nothing so i don't have emotions
i have a job to do i have to take care
of my family i have to make sure that
the egg the nest egg is done properly so
i don't do crazy stuff that's why i
don't be out here i can while i have to
protect this because if this goes away
everything goes away my father told me
don't let anybody take your mother's
house away
remember that i was like what do you
mean by that he said when you get rich
you're going to buy your mom a house now
you know 60 of athletes after they're
done they have nothing and if you ain't
got nothing we ain't got nothing
that that sticks in me don't let nobody
take your mama house away don't let
anybody take your kid's house away so i
think about stuff like that so when you
talk about emotion i don't really have
emotions
well it's interesting to hear you say
that you don't have emotions um because
i remember when i was watching your
interview on the pivot you talk about
having a lot of sleepless nights and the
things that you're thinking about at
night why you can't go to sleep and to
me that signals it's because at night
you are ruminating on things that have
happened to you how they have affected
you how you deal with them you maybe
don't see that as like emotion
but there is something in you
that is thinking about life in different
ways yes because when you're real you
realize when you mess up
bro i live in a 30 thousand square foot
house by myself you don't think i know i
messed up
my wife was fired as hell
i had it my babies are beautiful i'm i'm
in here by myself i messed up
it's the ones that don't know when they
mess up as the ones that don't ever make
it messed up
once you live with it
my sister i got a picture of her right
in the walking house i messed up the day
she passed away i should have called her
should have called her before that
see momma typed that i'm working so hard
hey taylor want to interview on
wednesday i i see taylor in the building
all the time let's let's you know let's
telltale i do it friday rather than me
saying taylor i can't do it like
it's always i gotta cause remember
protect provide and love and you can put
it in any order mine is provide
protecting that so let let me work and
i'll call you later but
by the time i get home i never call so
you know same thing with kobe so let me
text them and call them and those are
the things that you think about you
should have shared a shoulder shutter
and
that's why i tell people now
don't shut up
don't cut up take care of it
man i could have called them no call i
don't care if you had arguments beefs
you want to know that send them a tweet
send them a text or something so those
are the things like when you when you
realize you messed up
you don't want to
you don't want to have that on your
heart but it's going to always be on my
heart
the rest of my life and i i got ways of
dealing with it
and just you know think it through and
you just think about the good times
that's your way of dealing it dealing
with it think about it at times
do you feel like
you ever would have called
yeah probably
because because
the crazy thing is even though it seemed
like we were enemies not enemies it's
just what you know just what brothers do
you argue like me and charles are gonna
fight all the time to the point when
when i go to the airport you're like you
really hate them oh man that's my boy
i love y'all if i if i'm outside with
y'all somebody say something charles
right now we are going to be fighting
charles is my guy same thing with kobe
and i always tell people i say
if you don't think we hate it so much
and i want you to play this clip
first championship it's a hundred
thousand people on the floor
who the first guy to jump in my arms
do you do brothers have arguments all
the time do boys have arguments all the
time
that's what we do but the respect thing
was there
that's and and and
and that's what i try to tell people in
life
i don't have to agree with you miss
rooks
but i'm never going to disrespect you
like you think i should apologize to
that young man
no i just asked if you thought you
should
but i'm just giving you another you
think beautiful lovely miss rooks i
actually apologize i say no i'm not i
respect you conversation stops there
yeah now who do you think you're no i
don't i'm not no i know taylor she
perfected no
you think i suppose i'm not proud of
y'all boom i said and that's what we had
he said something i say something
respect was there
so but yeah i just like i'm to tell you
that i'm working so hard i don't like
bothering people yeah
like bothering people so i've heard you
you know talk about you know you and
kobe you had a very brother relationship
it wasn't that you were enemies
why did it get to the place where
everyone believes
there was this deep dislike that's what
i intended it for it's called marketing
the master of marketing i know how to
get you to look at me even now i'll say
some stuff just to say it just because i
know you're going to react
marketing 101.
hey you got to look at me i want you to
look at me
yeah i want you to look at him i want
you to look at the lakers i know exactly
what i'm doing yeah exactly what i'm
doing so but again
kobe had a guy
you know we all got egos colby said what
no and then i have my guy
and then it gets out but who are you
talking about
what year is this
what year is this
when did me and him last play
what two thousand
four years okay so what's that 18 years
so my marketing has lasted 18 years so
far because you still ask me these
questions so i know exactly what i was
doing
exactly like you i'm this this is
marketing one-on-one oh they got beef
oh they don't like each other oh this
that when every time i got double team
who would i pass it to every time he
drew five people and what are you
dropping off to that's because the
respect was there
you would think though that inherently
had to creep into the locker room in
some form or fashion never creeps in my
locker room i was the general
yeah nothing creeps in and if it did we
handle it like men and then we move on
listen like the outsiders think
everything needs to be oh hello hello no
hey man you got the focus you got your
white balance all right boom boom boom i
said like
it's respect the respects need to be
there that that that's all that matters
like i don't have to like you but i have
to respect you
i don't have to like her but i have to
respect her
and she would respect me more
if i respect her
like she don't care if i like her she
just want me to respect that she's
directing the show she like when i walk
down the hall she stopped me she wanted
me to respect her hey
we're not doing that you need to get
mike you need to walk back the cameras
are rolling right away yes ma'am i saw
that i
turned it off and
that's what life is all about and we
have respect for each other that's why
we can win three in a row that's why 20
years later
you're still talking about the
most dominant most enigmatic most
controversial one-two punch ever
never to be duplicated ever again but
again like a lot of that was my fault
because i
i'm silly everybody knows shaq is silly
i want you to talk about me i want you
to think i'm fighting i want you to
think i hate him yes i'm like was he as
on board with this
no he didn't know but like he was
defending himself but i know if i take
them off i know i get him to play at a
high level i knew that
because he was just like me and he knew
that if you take me off i'm playing at a
high level yeah like i say so like
because in all the games right
win or lose is still my fault like
somebody could miss 50 shots but if i
miss four free throws it's my fault and
then i'll say stuff like well i only
missed free throw because i ain't
touched the ball the last three minutes
which makes you think oh we talking
about
right oh so i i knew i knew exactly what
i was doing so the next game he either
gonna throw it to me every time we're
gonna keep shooting so i i knew i knew
exactly what i was doing
so as you kind of talk about just you
know this way you view life the way you
live life you're talking about you know
being in this home by yourself thinking
about things at night
are you a lonely person would you say
you're lonely i'm alone or daddy what
movie is that i'm not sure you never
watched pee-wee herman anybody know i've
watched people here but i shouldn't be
real
i'm a loner daddy
right but there's a difference between
being lonely and being a loner are you
lonely
no i'm not lonely because i know how to
get out and a record people but i am a
loner yeah i like being alone
gives me time to think think about your
mistakes think about you did something
today is that right does it get on
program not to make the same mistake
twice yeah my job is to continue to make
people smile and make people happy
that's what i like if i could do
something for somebody
you know my new thing is when i go to
best buy in walmart i'm looking for moms
and kids
because they used to be me and my mom
so the last one the lady was in the
layaway section and i'm here hustling
and she's going back and forth so if i
bring a hundred this month or next month
and get the laptop i'm like nope
about to get the laptop right now lady
that's good because that's that's what
dr lucille o'neill told me to do so you
need to go out and make it better for
other people thousand dollars ain't
nothing to me
but this mom and them two little babies
there you go can i put it on facebook
i'd rather you don't do that mom
well i want to say thank you
it's good and then i grab the little
kids hey you want to be rich and famous
like me yeah yeah yeah you sure about to
tell my secret make sure you listen to
your mommy and daddy
cause that's how i got to where i am
today i didn't let my dad's on i made up
700 on the sat
700 yeah
700 and on the act i think i made a 19.
so i wasn't the prop 48 i was able to
play but like i'm not the smartest
knife in the drawer but i like not being
the smartest guy in the room because i
get to learn something
yeah i can buy this camera but it's not
going to make me a dp but i'm talking to
my man right there i know you've been
working here a long time he's going to
tell me everything i need to know
and general eisenhower said the greatest
of leaders are the ones smart enough to
hire people smarter
and that's why i'm still successful i
got a lot of smart people working for me
yeah and i'm not eric and i'm not
arrogant i listen
like my crew can tell me when i mess up
anybody in my crew because it's a real
crew you know man you shouldn't have did
that yeah
what you doing stop don't do that no
more and i'll listen that's why we're
still here i don't i don't know more
than you
because i make more money than you i'm
not better than you because i make more
money than you i don't look down on you
that's not what i do
i respect the people who make me who i
am today
i remember when
you're going into the hall of fame phil
jackson penned a letter to you
and in that letter he's talking about
how he would ask his player sometimes to
do book reports
and at one point he gave you the book
said hartha
and you actually did the book report
and he said that the first line of your
book report said
siddhartha is a book about a young
prince who has money fame and women just
like me
he is also searching for self-discovery
just like i am
when you wrote that what point
in your self-discovery journey
were you at
i realized that phil jackson
because he's a scholar
he would look at certain people and be
like okay he's this and he would give
you these books
and you read and you read those journeys
i was like oh okay but what phil doesn't
understand is cliffnotes.com
had just opened up at that time i didn't
read that book i'm not reading no down
but i got a season to play
on that ass but did you mean that
that's what it said in the cliff notes
but did you feel like you were like him
in that way no when i read the cliff
notes i knew what what i was talking
about we don't have a heart out you
don't have to worry about that hey we
ain't got no heart out when i leave is
when we leave yeah we're good i'm
enjoying myself but really either
cliffnotes.com
understand that no i just
so it told me the cliff knows what the
book was going to be about
right and i understand that i understand
you're saying you didn't read it that's
fair but what i'm saying is what you
wrote did you believe that you did
resonate with him in that way i did
young famous whatever
and then i said okay he's on the journey
my journey is to win this championship
guess what so when i turned in my little
book report that was just to keep phil
off because he said did you read the
book of your book not read no damn books
no not read no book phil jackson
i think it's really cool that he like
made you guys do that though yeah even
and he said you were the only person
that ever actually turned in a report it
was a thing he said but no one did it he
was like he gave me this paper and he he
wrote this but you know everyone is on a
journey of self-discovery so it's not
incorrect that you wrote that about the
book
thank you do you feel like you're still
on a journey of self-discovery or do you
think that you have a good sense of who
you are i don't know who i am but it's
it's it's it's never about me yeah i
realized that earlier about me yeah
especially when you have kids i ain't
about you anymore but you when you have
a mother
never about me so again i got
i got 50 people when i wake up i'm
worried about 50 people i worry about
myself so
if i can get through 50 and then have
time for myself
then i'll work with myself but other
than that
okay
i want to have a general conversation um
about
something you touched on on the pivot
when you were here i knew it she already
warned me about it
when you were talking about
your marriage your divorce a thing that
you said
over and over in that was i was bad it
was bad
what did you mean by you know what i
mean but you know the rules of marriage
stop it
my job is to ask you and you have to
tell me so that i'm not implying it and
we need some clarification are you
referring to infidelity
when it comes to marriage we know the
rules of marriage and i broke all the
rules we don't need to discuss what i
was doing okay because you you just
opened all rooms i was bad i was the
worst
and she did the right thing
well when it comes to and again this is
general conversation marriage she's good
um
i like her
as you know as a
as a person who you know obviously
thinks about love things about marriage
thinks about what these things are
things about the type of man you are
supposed to be with and these and things
like that
and we have this conversation and i said
to you i said i don't ever i don't want
to date a famous person
and you said it's not about being famous
about access
explain to me what you meant by that
about access and discipline
any good looking guy has extra
access
one person look at you two people look
at you
you have name behind that
times five times ten
you have to have the discipline
it takes discipline you don't have to
let with all these chats and dms
don't matter who you are
people like good looking people people
like nice people what if you're dating a
guy that's not nice and then somebody
gets in your dm and it's nice
you don't have interest so you know
we have a little more options but
it's still all the same
but as a man you have to have the
discipline if you don't have the
discipline
you make up excuses on why you did it
everything i did is an excuse the crazy
thing is i know better
i've seen my mom and my dad my dad was
protect provided in love
see that's that's a man's job most guys
can give you two
i've seen a man give three
well that that's the thing i was gonna
say i think there is some
irony in this because
you can be disciplined about the things
you want to be disciplined about like
you're clearly disciplined you won
championships but so but if i i talk
about being undisciplined it was an
excuse
i don't make excuses
that's why i can say i messed up
or i can be like no
i told her i don't wear those shoes and
she wore us so i no i said excuse i
don't make excuses for my state real men
don't make excuses when they mess up
yeah i messed the whole thing up i
messed the whole operation up
just by being stupid
by being greedy
yeah
does it hurt you to have to talk about
it
it's my second time talking about it in
my last time
i'll never i only only talk about it
with you because i respect you
and i like you
i'm never going to talk about it again
but i can say i could look in the mirror
and say you messed up
why'd you mess up don't matter
see when you talk about why you did up
and you just
created more excuses and
opening doors that don't need to be open
like when i say i was bad every
everybody know what that mean come on i
don't need to oh it was wet no you know
i was the worst
she's happy now she's getting married
yes and that's great happy birthday
she's with a fine gentleman now i hope
she treats her like she's probably
treated so when you talk about protect
provide and love what did you learn
about love
after that
i love that it's unconventional
and it's not all about you
see when i was the man it's all about me
do this do that
but like i'm sacrificing for everybody
now you have to sacrifice first
you got to sacrifice what does your
woman want
she like those shoes shut your face and
let her wear those shoes it's gonna make
her feel comfortable shut up
nah don't be wearing no shoes that it no
if she want to wear it you want to look
good and feel good it's going to be good
for you at the end of the night trust me
be quiet
i didn't know that
i didn't have any experience with being
a boyfriend never had it just just
happened right away yeah
so
you got one you have to live like if you
don't protect and provide and love you
sometimes you just got to shut your face
and let the woman be a woman a lot of us
guys especially when we get money we
like do this and do that and that never
works
especially in the long run so now i know
how to
you look beautiful yeah love you
and it'll be a great night instead of
you know stood out because
i was always it was about me it's always
about me me me me me me me and then the
goddess told me you know that that'll
never work
that's why you always go put mo mo you
two mean youtube bossy
yeah like for real
she's like i can teach you and she
finally sat me down i was like i've been
doing it wrong
oh my god
so would you say you're you're genuinely
a better man than a partner oh yeah
yeah so all that stuff i mean in a lot
of ways was necessary for you to grow
and be who you needed to be when it
called for you to be i don't know if it
was necessary i wish i'd had this
information yeah
i just didn't have the information but
now that i have it i'm nice i think it's
easy sometimes for people to just
get caught up in either who they are in
their life that's an excuse
right but so that's what i want to say
how would you
advise somebody to how do you avoid that
how do you avoid being caught up in this
moment of who you are and all the things
that are available to you because this
story you're telling is not singular you
are not unique in this this happens
you understand what i'm saying so before
you bring
someone into your world just
got to communicate with them you have to
be ready
yeah you got to be ready
okay
if you're not ready just say i'm not
ready
yeah and stay with the people that ain't
ready with you
i ain't ready and ready
ready and ready works ain't ready i
ain't ready works i ain't ready and
ready it'll work for a small amount of
time but not
yeah so you're not if you're not ready
stay over there with the people that
ain't ready because a lot of people over
there ain't ready yeah there's a lot of
people that's ready so i was
you know i was i was ready because i was
having children but i wasn't really
ready yeah but that's growth and that's
life you
you figure out who you are and you get
quiet and you get better oh stop and i'm
happy i'm happy that you have arrived
and you're here and that's taylor
victoria
taylor sasha rooks stop it axe do you
wanna know my middle name
taylor lynn
oh where you from georgia yeah it's so
good taylor lynn you better get your ass
in this house
it's very very southerners
you better get your ass in this house
but i've always felt like i don't think
i look like a tailor
i feel like
no you're only saying that because my
name is taylor but i don't mail quicker
taylor who you look like
like vanessa
stop it i think i just look like a
different name oh girl stop you don't
look like a vanessa i don't my my mom
always my dad wanted to name me tiffany
and she was like i don't think she's a
tiffany she's a tailor she's got to be a
team taylor's is in the middle yeah it
was really important to my mom actually
to give my sister and i uh unisex names
ryan so she wanted us to have
you know names that could also be more
names ryan rooks that's nice that she
has a good name like those devil r's
i should have been ryan for sure um oh a
couple more where i let you go
winning time are you watching it yeah
i'm watching that's nice all right if
you're not let me go on there yeah they
already said they can talk about me
no that's something i was gonna ask
well let me go on record and say i do
not like the way they are depicting
jerry west i'm gonna go on the air and
say that so okay because
jerry was never like that around me
ever and it was a time for him to be
going crazy that was the time yeah the
stuff that we were putting everybody
through but he was never like that so so
you're like that's
your question i was gonna say if next
season it is you who do you want to play
you i was thinking about that but if it
is me do what you want i don't care
another thing about me i'm programmed
not to be sensitive yeah the reason why
i can take chris i've been criticized
all my life
since a little kid
so you learn to do you either
or you
i'm learning to deal with it i learned
to deal with it it took me four years to
get over that
man this dude's ten and he he can't even
touch he's six eight he can't touch the
room he'll never make the nba
you know the girls huh look at him he's
ugly he got big feet like i've been so
now i got you can't it ain't none and
nothing you can say that's gonna make me
you know that's gonna arousal my
feathers if it does i'll say something
back yeah and if it gets to certain
levels then it you know it's gonna have
to be what it's going to be but i'm not
like most of these guys where you see
stuff
like them oh okay
yeah if it's funny i'll laugh
okay like i encourage you once put send
out a twenty funny tweet funny maybe
about me please do please do it yes okay
so with that being said i know you're
not sensitive i know you're like
everything that has happened in my life
happened and
i was thinking for all these things but
what is the thing that they could talk
about in winning time that you're like
i'd be portrayed in a bad light here i
maybe was wrong here i don't care
and i understand that i don't care i
don't know i don't care there's not a
thing you're like yeah people are going
to think i even though you don't care
there has to be a moment in your career
like
as a leader you have to do
and say certain things to get your
troops to respond to a certain level
i don't know i don't care but guess what
it
ain't that bad i'm not in jail
i'm sitting here talking to to vanessa
rooks
it's gonna catch on okay i'm telling you
it is absolutely vanessa rooks
vanessa rooks doesn't work but the name
vanessa though i know people are gonna
team me like girl what are you talking
about and that's fine that's fair um
on the um subject of the lakers in
winning time definitely have to talk to
you about that you know genie bus
obviously came out today and talked
about
all the money that she spent on the team
and she felt like it obviously failed
and she's um upset about that what are
your words to genie best i love genie
bus i would never have anything bad to
say about me
she's great or the best family yeah hey
it's business sometimes you make
investments they work out and they don't
we we move on right i'm not here to
criticize ms bustin she should have did
this [ __ ] i don't know i don't know what
she should have done just miss jeannie
i'll support you
i love you hope you and rob get it
together and
bring us back to prominence cause the
problem with us la fans was spoiled yeah
we're used to having the top players we
used to go into the fine we used to win
a championship and when you don't get
that
people go crazy she knows that she
understands that's why she lebron
haiti
carmelo westbrook because we used to
have big names play together and work
together but this time it didn't work
but
it's okay genie you said something
interesting in an interview once when
you were talking about lebron you said
right now the issue is that these
players no longer fear lebron because
you know what at some point
the student must kill the master to
become the master
and lebron is the aging master
so this is everybody's opportunity i
wish i was playing right now
because i've been through this
when i first came in
so the reason why i've been
successful and never had any ups and
downs because i'm used to the ups and
downs
when i first started in high school i
wasn't the top i made to the top high
school player ah i'm the man they only
get the cause i'm like damn i'm not the
man but that's okay i know what i got to
do i'm the number one college player
then when i get to the nba oh my god
mike
dominique bird so i'm playing i'm trying
to get to the top and then george oh
jordan's left
jordan lee's for the year
this shit's mine all mine so like i was
i was a student for a while but now it's
my turn to be the master jordan's gone
this shit's mine i'm taking over so
that's what tatum
all these guys are saying okay lebron
you could think about it and then as a
player like i remember i used to have
good games i used to run the tnt espn
talking about mike again i'm like damn
it's like a it's like a like you know
professional jealousy then they talking
about charles man they talk about dave
ross oh they're talking about a guy
younger than me tim duncan it's like a
professional jealousy so
look lebron had to spot too long it
ain't nothing personal but
he gonna be gone two or three years and
y'all just saying this my league right
now
y'all honestly saying that taylorman
saying hey i just put kd away you know
better recognize my name steph curry
said oh no no no i'm still here so
but as a fan that's what makes the game
so
so great yeah no absolutely and i think
that you you are right and one thing
that we do on the show is you do a top
five what show is this now i don't even
know the show brooks and so your episode
is taylor rex and shaq oh so you got
your own show yeah i'll see you boo boo
i see you vanessa i see you vanessa
taylor and vanessa
but no we do a top five segment um and
you kind of segued right into it because
the top five i was gonna ask you is as
we look at this kind of next generation
of who's gonna take over the league tell
me those that top five for you i don't
know
well you said stuff you said giannis you
said no stuff steph is older steph's on
his way out so jason tatum
yeah jason you know
giannis okay
jason tatum
help me out here people uh there's ja
there oh yeah oh my god i'm sorry
yeah oh luca luca
one more
there's trey
there's uh
yeah there's some good ones that's true
right now you've said giannis uh jason
luca jaw yeah
number five so my father
some names out there there's donovan
there's trey
uh awesome i forget about the young guys
there's like so many young guys yeah but
they don't count yet because like if you
if you can't if they don't come right
those are the ones like i said they come
right through i mean there's jaylen
brown too yeah right yeah he's close
he's not just so there's trey and
donovan
since i've been on donald i'm gonna go
ahead and give to donovan
give him some love no i ain't gonna give
him no love
oh i don't i i
i don't do love
i do tough love but but i'm gonna give
it to him cause i know he has the
potential so you you can either prove me
right or prove me wrong okay sounds good
i do have a final one i just i'm curious
i'm curious
obviously love you on inside the nba
everybody loves you on inside the nba
what is the end in sight how long do you
want to do it i don't know
think about it all the time
i don't know so i have one
gorgeous little baby left she'll be in
high school
so
four years of college so i i something
after four years
because i i tell my kids in order to
touch my cheese
you gotta have a few degrees so my
oldest daughter is fabulous she's a
uh marketing director for pepsi she's
doing great
yeah my oldest son is doing great he's
also a dj in nft space and all that i
got three in college
texas southern uh
me and me shakir
and sharif i don't know what he's going
to do he's going to go back or go in the
draft i'm not sure yet but that's my
youngest miara so she's 16 two years of
high school four years of college so
that's six years so after everybody's in
and out of college then i probably can
just
fade away into the abyss
yeah you said you think about it all the
time you really do because i told you
when i wake up i gotta think about 50
people before i think about myself yeah
okay who do you think
who do you think shaq is
when he's not in front of us being shaq
well shaq is a regular dude i denounced
my celebrities six months ago
celebrities are [ __ ]
i want to be affiliated with them people
and people crazy
they're disrespectful
they step on people they look down on
people that's not what i do
when i go to mcdonald's and order food
for me and my fat friends and the kids
bring it i'll give them a 200 tip
i'm not about to go in there and cook it
and do it you're doing that for me
appreciate your big homie thank you yeah
that's what we need more in this world
we got too much hey i got this i got
that
nah that ain't me so
when you see shaq you're going to see
him by himself he ain't gonna be no
entourage you're not gonna be
disrespectful we ain't gonna be throwing
people around when i go to the
restaurant with my boys they're amazed i
don't skip the line
hey man go to the front no man i'm not
skipping that lady i can't do it yeah i
know i'm gonna shack and i can eat free
i just can't i can't do it because
remember these people right here make
this world go around not me
yeah but but it but it's my job to
entertain them
and then when they pay that's how i get
paid
so it's all a certain ecosystem that
could never be broken a lot of people
break it so when you turn your back on
them then they get all sour and get all
sad but you got to protect the people
that make you your so
when you see shaq shaq's a cool regular
dude he's going to be by himself and i
can attest i think both you and chuck
are two of the like most generous people
of all time and when it comes inside the
nba i think we are all so deeply lucky
to have you on that show so i hope you
do what about rebecca
do i look like a rebecca yes you do i
don't know if i look like rebecca
rebecca rook what do we think guys
rebecca uh because you said you like
double arse i do
hi i'm shaquille o'neal the co-host of
the rebecca
i'm here with the lovely rebecca rooks
no thank you for your time thank you for
coming on so proud thank you and you are
fantastic and i'll ask you no more uh
personal questions yeah you guys this is
his last interview where he's talking
about any of the personal questions i'm
turning right now deletes manual
well thank you for sitting here and
answering this no problem
but that's so if you don't get out of
here with
that quickness
[Music]